it's kind of good news that zilinski is
losing Time Magazine has published their
front page story zalinski is desperate
to win but his advisers saying they've
lost the war Russia is winning they're
losing the War I should say to to be
clear and there's little interest in the
US to continue funding what is already
lost as we we said this some time ago it
looks like Russia's won this one in the
meantime however it looks like things
are escalating over Israel we've got
other breaking news that Israel has now
taken uh has admitted to bombing a
refugee camp killing at least 50
civilians and uh apparently the went on
CNN they said they did it so things are
getting absolutely horrifying right now
and as this escalates there's concern
with other nations saying that if Israel
keeps keeps up these bombing campaigns
which kill civilians then it's going to
escalate further hopefully as we see
Ukraine wind down the things that are
escalating in the in in the Middle East
do not become a World War III scenario
or go beyond the region